you see what you call by the lake in the
back of his LA home flea likes to
practice
it's a rare tranquil moment in what's
been a monumental year for the bass
player in March his band the Red Hot
Chili Peppers played the pyramids in
Egypt it's like the wonders of the world
that's one of them right and just last
month flea was married to designer
melody asani congratulations thank you
been twiddling with my wedding ring for
like four days now I found this
incredible woman this is your place now
he's published a memoir so long I didn't
run a write a book about myself because
I thought what an arrogant thing to do
but acid for the children is not a tale
of rock star glory it's a reflection on
a vulnerable childhood you were a lonely
kid I was was it hard to write about
that the writing wasn't hard but when I
would read it out loud I would break
down in tears all the time
I mean I'm 57 I stopped doing drugs
drinking alcohol when I was about 30 and
then I started feeling everything and
sometimes it was a river of pain he was
born Mike Bowser II in Melbourne
Australia in 1967 his father who worked
in customs for the government was posted
to New York and took the family they
lived an ordinary life in the suburbs
until his mother left his dad and moved
in with her guitar teacher we go to live
with a junkie jazz musician who lives in
his parents basement that's quite a
change it was a massive change as
dysfunctional imposing and wounded as
Walter was flea writes of his future
stepfather he was also my angel one day
Walter Urban invited his jazz musician
friends over to jam that day awakened
something in me that you know changed my
life forever you still feel it now it's
such a powerful moment like when I think
about it and I was the first time I saw
it as a kid I couldn't believe it
man I just was taken over by the spirit
they were magicians to me it was magic
you've got a stepfather who causes
enormous disturbance no in your life it
was terrifying but also gives you this
gift yeah but he was taking that pain
and feels like what is alchemy turning
pain into something beauty which is what
all you know that's what I was about in
1972
the family moved to LA where flea would
run wild when I was 12 years old I'd go
out till 4:00 or 5:00 in the morning
running the streets of Holly we're
looking for hustles do a little crimes
but at school he discovered the trumpet
you were in the band yeah yeah marching
band orchestra the musical production
band jazz band any band I could beat him
and in seventh grade competed for the
National Orchestra award
I played Joseph Haydn's trumpet concerto
I'd you know I think I played it pretty
well and won I won yeah and I got
private lessons I'm a trumpet and that
was a big win for me as a kid at school
he'd also find perhaps the most profound
relationship of his life you met Anthony
in a fight basically kinda yeah sort of
a fight it was 1976 and he was wrestling
with a classmate and here comes up this
kid he's got a crew-cut a hard buzz
crew-cut and he's big and he's muscly
and he's lay off him comes up to me lay
off him and it was Anthony and he had
just moved to to LA himself the universe
gives us the ones we need flea writes
and the ones we deserve Anthony Kiedis
would become the Chili Peppers frontman
we were both apart from things like both
outcasts in a way a relationship is
there's a strange one on a difficult one
and something that's one that's often
antagonistic we rub against each other
wrong ways maybe he understands it I
don't understand it I know that I love
him
deeply you also say that there's almost
no one who has had as much power to hurt
you is yeah your opposite sides of the
same coin
ones concave the others convex I think
that's kind of has a lot to do with how
our band ended up being having you know
the power that it does have the next
piece of the original Chili Peppers
would come together when the duo met
Hillel Slovak we see hello driving down
the street and his Datsun
his green dot two five ten yes
incredible car cranking stereo in it
I've never forget it he was playing
about a lobbyist Ron Giada by Russ
Slovak had a band and needed a bass
player he said to flee you know maybe
you should learn to play the bass I felt
just so you know loved why did that make
you feel so low because he you know he
picked me yeah I haven't played the bass
before mmm I never played the bass I
knew that being in a rock band meant
everything to him his band was a sacred
thing to him it's a special thing this
is us you know like and he invited me in
and that meant everything to it meant
everything to me and you know I never
would have played it that he not asked
me I never would have played the bass
fleas book ends just as the Chili
Peppers begin is there a sequel
I'm on the fence about it you're on the
fence why I got records to make and
tours to do and kids to raise and a wife
to love and you know if there's only so
many hours in the day but I do love
sitting and writing and it might happen